شددت وزيره خارجيه جنوب افريقيا
رئيس مجلس السلم والامن الافريقيه
على ضروره تسويه الصراعات الافريقيه في
اطار افريقي اشادت الوزيره التي تراس
بلادها الدوره الحاليه لمجلس السلمي
والامن الافريقي في تصريحات للجزيره
باتفاق بريتوريا الاخير بين حكومه اثيوبيا
وجبهات تحرير تيجراي
انه يوسف
بانه يجب ان نحل مشاكلنا بانفسنا لذلك
ساعدنا بان العب دورا في اتفاقيه السلام
الاثيوبيه التوقيع ما هو الا خطوه اولى
والتنفيذ مهم جدا قدمنا تقريرنا لمجلس
السلم والامن الافريقي عن عمليه السلام
وتنفيذ الاتفاقيه وهذا يعطينا املا عظيما
في ان تتمكن افريقيا بالفعل من البدء في
تطوير الموارد اللازمه لمعالجه مشاكلها
وحلها والعمل على انهاء الصراعات
وبالنسبه لملف الارهاب اشاره رئيسه مجلس
السلمى والامن الافريقيه لامتلاك الاتحاد
الافريقي رؤيه شامله لمواجهه ما سمتها
بالحركات الارهابيه وكذلك وقت فانشطت
المرتزقه في القاره
نواجه مشاكل صعبه للغايه في موضوع الارهاب
في القاره الافريقيه ونود تفعيل القوه
الاحتياطيه للاتحاد الافريقي بحيث تلعب
دورا نشطا في وقف العنف الذي يحدث لاسيما
في منطقه الساحل لدينا رؤيه شامله لذلك
ورؤيه مماثله لوقف انشطه المرتزقه